game he would have said yeah with black
i'll definitely take the draw i get
white in the next one
i'm already one point up in today's
match but
yeah with the position on the board and
hikaru he came with the better homework
in this game magnus tried to surprise
him
nakamura got the better opening in the
end so
um i do think this is his moment of
strike he'll regret
taking the draw if he doesn't win
today's match um but the longer he
thinks the lower he gets on the clock
the more tempting it will become
to take the draw yeah and he's he's
really debating it he's super unsure
he's going for it oh body language he's
done this before several times on the
tour
um and now will we see the position
repeat itself
if the queen's retreat magnus now takes
the draw threefold repetition
the game is over draw missed opportunity
for nakamura though
wow um magnus carlsen basically getting
a little lucky here it is a draw and
hikaru okay
he's hitting his head uh i think he just
turned on the analysis engine he
realized
black has a huge